Hi.
In this problem, we'll get
more practice using
conditioning to help
us calculate
expectations of variances.
We'll see that in this problem,
which deals with
widgets and crates, it's
actually similar in flavor to
an earlier problem that we
did, involving breaking a
stick twice.
And you'll see that in this
problem, we'll again use the
law of iterated expectations and
the law of total variance
to help us calculate
expectations of variances.
And again, we'll be taking the
approach of attacking the
problem by splitting into the
stages and building up from
the bottom up.
So in this problem, what we
have is a crate, which
contains some number of boxes.
And we don't know how
many boxes are.
It's random.
And it's given by some discrete
random variable, n.
And in each box, there are
some number of widgets.
And again, this is
also random.
And in each box, say for Box
I, there are xi number of
widgets in each one.
What we're really interested
in in this problem is, how
many widgets are there
total in this crate?
So in the crate, there are
boxes, and in the boxes, there
are widgets.
How many widgets are there
total within the crate?
And we'll call that a
random variable, t.
And the problem gives
us some information.
It tells us that the expectation
of the number of
widgets in each box for all
the boxes is the same.
It's 10.
And also, the expectation
of the number of
boxes is also 10.
And furthermore, the variance of
x of the number of widgets
and the number of
boxes is all 16.
And lastly, an important fact
is that all the xi's, so all
the widgets for each box, and
the total number of boxes,
these random variables
are all independent.
So to calculate t, t is just
a sum of x1 through xn.
So x1 is the number of widgets
in Box 1, z2 is the number of
widgets in Box 2, and all
the way through Box n.
So what makes this difficult
is that the
n is actually random.
We don't actually know how
many boxes there are.
So we don't even know how many
terms there are in the sum.
Well, let's take a slightly
simpler problem.
Let's pretend that we
actually know there
are exactly 12 boxes.
And in that case, the only thing
that's random now is how
many widgets there
are in each box.
And so let's call [? sum ?] a
new random variable, s, the
sum of x1 through x12.
So this would tell us,
this is the number of
widgets in 12 boxes.
All right.
And because each of these xi's
are independent, and they have
the same expectation, just by
linearity of expectations, we
know that the expectation of s
is just 12 copies of the same
expectation of xi.
And similarly, because we also
assume that all the xi's are
independent, the variance of
s, we can just add the
variances of each
of these terms.
So again, there are 12 copies
of the variance of xi.
So we've done a simpler version
of this problem, where
we've assumed we know what
n is, that n is 12.
And we've seen that in this
simpler case, it's pretty
simple to calculate what the
expectation of the sum is.
So let's try to use that
knowledge to help us calculate
the actual problem, where
n is actually random.
So what we'll do is use the law
of iterated expectations.
And so this is written in terms
of x and y, but we can
very easily just substitute in
for the random variables that
we care about.
Where in this case, what we see
is that in order to build
things up, it would be helpful
if we condition on something
that is useful.
And in this case, it's fairly
clear that it would be helpful
if we condition on n,
the number of boxes.
So if we knew how many boxes
there were, then we can drop
down to the level of widgets
within each box.
And then once we have that, we
can build up and average over
the total number of boxes.
So what we should do
is condition on n,
the number of boxes.
So what have we discovered
through this
simpler exercise earlier?
Well, we've discovered that if
we knew the number of boxes,
then the expectation of the
total number of widgets is
just the number of boxes times
the number of widgets in each
one, or the expectation of the
number of widgets in each one.
So we can use that information
to help us here.
Because now, this is basically
the same scenario, except that
the number of boxes
is now random.
Instead of being 12, it
could be anything.
But if we just condition on
the number of boxes being
equal to n, then we know
that there are
exactly n copies of this.
But notice that n here
is still random.
And so what we get is that the
expectation is n times the
expectation of the number of
widgets in each box, which we
know is 10.
So it's expectation of 10
times n or 10 times the
expectation of n, which
gives us 100.
Because there are, on
expectation, 10 boxes.
So this, again, makes
intuitive sense.
Because we know that on average,
there are 10 boxes.
And on average, each box
has 10 widgets inside.
And so on average,
we expect that
there will be 100 widgets.
And the key thing here is that
we actually relied on this
independence.
So if the number of widgets in
each box vary depending on--
or if the distribution of the
number of widgets in each box
vary depending on how many
boxes there were, then we
wouldn't be able to
do it this simply.
OK, so that gives us the answer
to the first part, the
expectation of the total
number of widgets.
Now let's do the second part,
which is the variance.
The variance, we'll again use
this idea of conditioning and
splitting things up, and use
the law of total variance.
So the variance of t is going to
be equal to the expectation
of the conditional variance
plus the variance of the
conditional expectation.
So what we have to do now is
just to calculate what all of
these pieces are.
So let's start with
this thing here,
the conditional variance.
So what is the conditional
variance?
Well, again, let's go back
to our simpler case.
We know that if we knew what n
is, then the variance would
just be n times the variance
of each xi.
So what does that tell us?
That tells us that, well, if
we knew what n was, so
condition on n, the variance
would just be n times the
variance of each xi.
So we've just taken this analogy
and generalized it to
the case where we don't actually
know what n is.
We just condition on n, and we
still have a random variable.
So then from that, we know that
the expectation now, to
get this first term, take
the expectation of this
conditional variance, it's just
the expectation of n and
the variance of xi,
we're given that.
That's equal to 16.
So it's n times 16, which we
know is 160, because the
expectation of n, we
also know, is 10.
All right, let's do this
second term now.
We need the variance
of the conditional
expectation of t given n.
Well, what is the conditional
expectation of t given n?
We've already kind of
used that here.
And again, it's using the fact
that if we knew what n was,
the expectation would just be n
times the expectation of the
number of widgets in each box.
So it would be n times the
expectation of each xi.
Now, to get the second
term, we just take
the variance of this.
So the variance is the variance
of n times the
expectation of each xi.
And the expectation
of each xi is 10.
So it's n times 10.
And now remember, when you
calculate variances,
[? if you ?] have a constant
term inside, when you pull it
out, you have to square it.
So you get 100 times
the variance of n.
And we know that the variance
of n is also 16.
So this gives us 1600.
All right.
So now we've calculated
both terms here.
The first term is
equal to 160.
The second term is
equal to 1600.
So to get the final answer,
all we have to
do is add this up.
So we get that the final answer
is equal to 1760.
And this is not as obvious as
the expectation, where you
could have just kind
of guessed that it
was equal to 100.
So again, this was just another
example of using
conditioning and the laws of
total variance and iterated
expectations in order to help
you solve a problem.
And in this case, you could kind
of see that there is a
hierarchy, where you
start with widgets.
Widgets are contained in boxes,
and then crates contain
some number of boxes.
And so it's easy to
just condition and
do it level by level.
So you condition on the
number of boxes.
If you know what the number of
boxes are, then you can easily
calculate how many widgets
there are, on average.
And then you average over the
number of boxes to get the
final answer.
So I hope that was helpful.
And we'll see you next time.